الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاكثر اهميه في
تاريخ تركيا الحديث اعدتنا الى جنوب
البلاد وتحديدا مناطق الزلزال التي يعود
اليها ايضا ابنائها الناجون النازحون بعد
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر عن الكارثه
السيده هوليا قدمت من العاصمه انقره حيث
تعيش مع اقاربها منذ حدوث الزلزال
تقف اليوم على اطلال ما تبقى من بيتها هنا
بهاتاي مذهوله من مال المدينه بعد الكارثه
ذكرت اخذتها
داخل مراكز الاقتراع امتزجت مشاعر
العائدين حنين الى ماضي انطاكيا ما قبل
الزلزال والم تذكر فقد الاحبه والاهل
الذين قضوا في الكارثه
بسبب الزلزال واليوم بعد عوده الى هنا
للانتخاب تذكرتها وتالمت كثيرا لرحيلها
اطلعنا
جيراننا رفيقنا غايبيننا الله يعطي الصبر
رحنا على بره هلا جينا ما شاء الله نحن
اخوات نفس الاخوات ما جار ابقاء شرط
التصويت بولايه الاقامه الاصليه اجبر مئات
الالاف من النازحين من الولايات المنكوبه
على العوده ولو مؤقتا
لم يفوتوا فرصه تفقد بقايا ركام منازلهم
ما اعاد للمدينه الخاليه شيئا من نبض
الحياه الى حين عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات